hey guys my name is Jess it is the 26th
I'll uh kotoba and you're watching games
but news first up the ps4 is getting to
third-party controllers which seem to be
similar in style to the Xbox one elite
controller the new controllers are
coming from razor and nakhon and while
they don't have a North American release
yet they will be arriving in Germany
before Christmas a post on Germany's
PlayStation Blog said that both
controllers are designed for
professional gamers and the eSports
scene the razor Roger features two extra
shoulder buttons two removable rear
triggers and a hair trigger option the
knock-on revolution Pro instead flips
the position of the left analog stick
and d-pad till more closely resemble the
xbox controller it also comes with four
shortcut buttons an eight-way d-pad
internal compartments for storing weight
and high precision and log sticks both
controllers can store multiple profiles
for remapping buttons and each have a
3.5 millimeter headset jack so there's a
one-up on the new iphone price is yet to
be announced for these two but stay
tuned to gamespot for more info Marquez
ought to have announced the free Windows
10 creators update I'm here the things
you want to know about that the update
will offer game broadcasting support
using the service beam which microsoft
acquired earlier this year viewers can
give feedback about what they see in
real time and since the features built
into Windows 10 anyone can stream
microsoft also confirmed the arena
tournament feature which lets players
create their own tournaments to compete
with friends is coming to the Xbox app
on PC the creator's update also lets you
scan objects with your phone to see a 3d
visualization of them and 3ds also
coming to windows paint and powerpoint
an early version of the update will be
available to windows inside it this week
while the full version is set to arrive
next spring finally Nintendo have said
they will ship two million switch
consoles during the financial year
ending months 2017 nintendo president at
suny kumashima was reported making this
statement by the wall street journal's
takashi mochizuki
on Twitter today kimishima added that
the switch won't be sold at a loss which
might suggest that the price of the
hardware could be higher than expected
but the CEO said Nintendo is listening
to what consumers expect from us when
setting price generally hardware is sold
at a loss with the intent to recoup
those losses on software sales Kirishima
added that upon the switches full reveal
he expects consumers will see how the
platform is different from Nintendo's of
the portable console the three DS
Nintendo switches to our next March that
is everything I have for you today do
let me know where you cared about head
to gamespot for stories on destiny and
sub 6 and I'll see you again tomorrow